hey guys the three of us have played
three hours of pace of Assassin's Creed
pahala so exciting assassin's creed is
back what we're gonna do in this video
is rundown on what we thought of this
setting what has changed and what's
interesting about the combat the skills
have been revamped how they're doing all
those things there's a lot to cover off
on so without further ado what do you
guys think about Assassin's Creed
entering the world of Vikings how did
you find it all the Vikings is a lot
like the world of ancient Greece I must
say it's it's so striking how familiar
it instantly feels like like Odyssey
when you finish up into it just in a
different setting but you know a big
part of why people play Assassin's Creed
is because they like the setting you
know you know the different ways of
reconstructed history and you know place
places that you know we've only read
about in books that's what's interesting
about Assassin's Creed but for the most
part I did just feel like this was a
very familiar game except for maybe the
combat which we'll get into later yeah
but like the one glaring like difference
for me between like Odyssey and ball
holla
like setting wise I think this is almost
a detriment to it it's the fact that
everything is so flat like there's no
Hills there's no like major buildings or
landmarks to look out for and so there's
like nothing drawing my eye like oh I
want to go over there I want to explore
in that direction I'm like man I mean
maybe it's just this area that we played
I'm like it's nothing but gray marsh for
as far as the eye can see in every scene
yeah it's worth noting that we played in
England so you do start the game in
Norway and you have a settlement there
as well which is another one of the new
mechanics they're working through where
you you sort of build up a home base we
didn't get to see any of that but we did
see a lot of countryside so it is worth
mentioning that we being in the world
environment we're in played this on a
sort of unique circumstances Edie and I
went into the Ubisoft office but you
Jordan played this of the cloud correct
and I think we all only had access to a
1080p build so that sort of explains why
you're seeing the quality of
now and it is a work in progress to
build this is not the final product of
the game I gotta say playing a 1080p
game on a 4k TV just blown up is like
not the best way to play a game it's not
but you know it's it's we're not 100%
sure how it's going to actually end up
looking but yeah just just so you know
what you're looking at the live part
that I really enjoyed which is what I
was excited for for Valhalla is the sort
of vibrancy of the Vikings and I got
that in one part of the demo which was a
scene that took place right before a
wedding and you could sort of walk
around and there were like little mini
games like a drinking mini game that
sort of played out like the UM the
rhythm Jim games that you do in Final
Fantasy 7 remake that was really fun
that felt very like trying to inject the
world of Assassin's Creed with something
new that could be quintessentially
Viking without being stupid depressing
which is what I was sort of worried this
game was tending towards although we did
talk a little bit about this and they've
been pretty serious about saying that
the historical accuracy is a front of
mind
so obviously Odyssey it was so much
about the mythical and gods and crazy
creatures and stuff and everything we
were told in the preamble to playing
this was that that was gonna be way less
of a focus not what a lot of us felt I
got I like touched like this mummy like
thing that spat blood on me and it
summoned like one of three sisters who
started creating fire clones of herself
and it was like I had to learn how to
fight her and like dodge her clones at
the same time I'm like this feels this
feels very fictional this feels very
yeah where's the grounded realism that I
was promised there was a lot of
different things I was running into I
can only call them like hell-blade esque
sites where the screen became very
heavily vendetta and it was all really
nasty and terrifying and they were like
strung up men on trays and stuff and you
had to shoot like our glowing horrible
skull and then it told you you cleanse
the area like so many things
Denmark there wasn't a lot of contacts
for what that meant or what I'd done I
just figured out that was the thing to
do and I did it a couple times yeah if
we should say that this the diamond that
we play takes place roughly mid game so
there was a lot of stuff that we didn't
have context for it's interesting that
combat I think seems a lot more grounded
to me and a lot harder
yeah combat definitely took a turn for
the more complex I don't want to say
complicated it's it's taking that dark
soul style of like light attack and
heavy attack and the other big thing is
you know as Vikings do they dual wield
weapons and actually quite found that
quite a lot of fun even though it is
still rooted in that very RPG style of
action combat and one of my favorite
things to do was experiment with what a
weapon does on your primary weapon hand
versus what it does on your secondary so
we ran to things like you know
one-handed axe with 200 axes Spears
flails and shields and things like the
flail which I found to be like a really
really slow and kind of a useless weapon
in the primary hand because you kind of
just need to charge doubly set yet in
the offhand you could just hold your
offhand button which is like l1 you just
start spitting it it's late and just
kind of like walk up to dues and just
like it's smacking them in the face so
joinee distinct to play with those
things I especially liked having to 100
axes together and using the offhand
attacks it just like whale again whale
on people which is a lot of fun but that
said remembering that a co2 see is an
RPG where you want to equip like the
weapon that does the highest damage all
the time I like I'm not sure how I'm
gonna be able to stick to my favorite
weapons a lot of the time I'll say I
really dug the combat like ACC has had
protagonists were quote-unquote dual
wheel there's for a long time now but
this one feels like the first instance
where I have actual control and agency
over how I want my main character to
play like I just went total aggression
in my place I'll just throwing axes just
slicing at people and only like bringing
out the shields
just quickly hairy people to do like
these almost like blood-borne esque
visceral attacks on people difficult and
I thought it was like really aggressive
and really fun and a far cry from the
very slow-paced wait for an enemy to
approach and then attack the next one
the next one in the next one that all
the older AC games have been kind of
known for for a while
the game also throws really tricky
enemies that you this like bazookas who
move incredibly fast and a var is quite
slow with any sort of I usually like
more roguish really quick builds but the
way that the character was designed in
the weapons I had access to meant that I
had to get back wait for those abilities
which we saw in Odyssey to get charged
up by taking out other enemies and then
just unleashing those really heavy
attacks and hoping that they did the job
I really like those super powerful
abilities they a lot of them feel
similar to Odyssey but some of them feel
like they're they're suited to Baja in a
way that you wouldn't have seen
Cassandra or Alexios dukes it wouldn't
have made sense for the character yeah
they've they're emphasizing the
brutality of the Vikings which you know
Pike is a brutal I guess so there are a
lot of like flashy finishes I mean the
whole Perry thing when you when you
parry or like just heavy attack a dude
to get there stagger down it to go in
for a finisher or to like unleash one of
your special abilities is kind of like a
big part of the flow it's just you want
to finish people off like in a really
spectacular way we had like a stomp
ability we click down an enemy just like
jump up and like crush their skull with
your foot or whatever and even even the
the bow and arrows they had a finisher
ability say Beast I gonna dude you could
shoot him in the head and it would look
flashy the skill upgrade system is quite
different to how it was in Odyssey and
Odyssey it was a lot more
straightforward and streamlined you just
picked abilities this is more of a
branching path of Exile style web which
upon first look is quite overwhelming
what did you guys think with that on
first look it looks simple because it it
just has all the abilities installation
and any zoom in here like oh my god you
have to unlock like this point and this
point then this point then I'll circle
back around to like unlock disability in
home legs I'm gonna have to level up
like five times just to unlock good yeah
ability yes so so they're like major
star points which I like the primary
abilities like I get that assassination
or like you know double assassination or
whatever but you do min and tangle
started just like +5 to melee damage is
like +5 to defense and all that kind of
[ __ ] but yeah there were like three
branches I want to say it was like Raven
bear and wolf and Raven basically dealt
with like assassination south techniques
or like dodgy sneaky techniques one one
that I saw was that assassination so you
can you know it's the kill a high-level
enemy the bear one was like more of the
brutality style finishes like doing
actual damage like the stomp and
adrenaline and the wolf is no need to do
with both abilities I want to say I was
saying all of the abilities were just so
at least as far as I could tell like
very open combat focused and like sort
of like Odyssey there's no actual towns
that you're visiting and so they've like
said before that there will be like
social stealth elements and I'm not
quite sure how that's going to come into
play I'm like there's not an actual
crowd like large enough for me to yeah
blend into and it seems like most of the
combat is very like in-your-face the
only like stealth moments for like oh
I'm going to engage this fort I'm gonna
try to like yes I have a few people and
assassinate a few people but then I'm
gonna get notice I'm gonna finish just
fighting everyone we do you only see
like a little part of the map there are
a ton of things are different you have a
longboat now it's kind of hard to use
it's all hard thank God for a drive yeah
yeah and thank God that you can actually
summon it from anywhere my biggest
qualms with Odyssey was I always had to
go to a fourth to like some of my ship
to me I'm like oh now I just go on the
quick wheel and just like come to me
another new activity that they have
introduced is something called raids
which kind of like assault is
about going into a town and like killing
a bunch of dudes
but also looting them for resources and
wealth for your liking clan I guess I
guess the big differentiating factor
here is that to do a raid you actually
need to like get your longboat along and
like bring your crew to a raid so they
can help you even though you're like a
one-person killing machine
aside from killing dudes in an area you
need to sort of search certain buildings
find keys to other buildings in order to
find more of the treasure chests and get
more wealth
oh we're either of you surprised to see
that essentially Assassin's Creed twos
medicine system was essentially back
where you could heal in the middle of a
fight like it's been gone Jackson's
Creed for so long they essentially
brought backs like oh now you have to
heal yourself both inside and outside of
combat it's just another one of those
like things that seems to be moving it
towards a more accessible style of Dark
Souls combat they're taking out its
Assassin's Creed and like open-world
games are just those kind of games that
kind of suck in a lot of good ideas from
other places to just have everything in
one one package you know these are the
kind of games that you know the one or
two games people buy a year and so you
kind of want a bit of everything
there's a lot of grit to it and it's
okay there's a lot of just scratching
the surface things that suggested to me
there will be some really dark heavy
supernatural like held lady elements and
things are gonna be a bit nasty and I
think if they really lean into that they
can tell some interesting stories it's a
year where we're gonna get a bunch of
open-world games that are all doing
something like interesting and new and
like combat and setting aside Valhalla
definitely just feels like Odyssey and I
feel like I've played it before
so I'm really curious to see what else
there is I remember playing The Odyssey
preview event and it was mostly focused
on like the conquest battles and a lot
of fighting things and I remember coming
away from that being like man is this
really all there is and then I played
Odyssey and I'm like oh there's actually
like some humor there's some decent side
quests and so I'm hoping that this is
basically the same thing that they've
just given us a very tiny
and it just was a segment that was just
really combat focused cuz I do like the
combat but if this games as long as
Odyssey which took me like 80 hours to
complete I don't want to just fight
people for 80 hours and just go from
point A to point B there's got to be
something else definitely and they try
to get a snapshot of a 80 hundred hour
game in like three hours yeah so let's
wait and see huh well be sure to stay
tuned for watching of this video we have
plenty more footage going up from
Assassin's Creed Valhalla keep your eyes
out for watchdogs Legion as well and
everything else from Ubisoft forward
thanks for joining us and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you